All right we're going to show you how
to create a CursorLoader in three
easy steps.
We start by creating an integer
constant for a Loader ID.
Then we implement the Loader Call backs.
Finally we initialize the Loader
with the LoaderManager.
We start just by creating a Loader ID,
which is an integer constant.
A single activity can
use multiple Loaders and
they are differentiated by these ID's.
The we have to fill in
the Loader Callbacks.
The Loader Callbacks
are a generic interface class,
with one parametrized type.
When we use the Loader Callbacks with a
CursorLoader, the parameterized type we
use is Cursor, which makes
the callbacks look like they do here.
The most interesting one for
us is onCreateLoader.
OnCreateLoader returns a loader
with parameterized type, Cursor.
This is where we create and
return our CursorLoader.
CursorLoader has a constructor that
takes all of the standard content
provider query parameters, and will
call the content provider on our behalf.
When it is executed
by the LoaderManager.
Since CursorLoader derives
an Async TaskLoader,
it will be executed in
a background thread.
OnLoadFinished is called when the loader
completes, and our data is ready.
To use the data in our cursor adaptor,
we just call SwapCursor,
but this is where we would also perform
any other UI updates we'd want to make
when the data is ready.
OnLoaderReset is typically only called
when our loader is being destroyed.
It means that we need to remove
all references to the Loader Data.
To do that we call SwapCursor
on our cursor adaptor with null.
Finally, we use the LoaderManager
to initialize our loader.
We pass in that loader ID,
the loader call back we just filled out,
and an optional bundle.
This will do all that cool life cycle
stuff we covered in the loader intro,
such as, calling onCreate loader if
the loader doesn't already exist.
When using loaders in a fragment,
we initialize our loader in
the onActivityCreated method.
And that's it,
you've got a basic CursorLoader.
We're going to have you write one for
our next exercise.